we'll have here in person for the first
time first of hopefully many times her
annual holiday tour starts November 24th
includes a stop in the beautiful
Michigan theater in Ann Arbor Michigan
and that's a perfect time for the tour
to start certainly since that allows my
next guests to go to tonight's game to
watch your beloved Chiefs take on the
Rams good to see Grammy Award winning
artist Melissa Etheridge how are you
pleasure to be here rich a pleasure to
have you here so let's start off first
you were kind enough to gently correct
me in the commercial break your children
are 12 not not baby so it's 12 year old
goods fine no babies no headphones no no
no no he'll be they'll be on their
phones kind of require earmuffs parts of
going in the Coliseum tonight indeed it
is I think there's gonna be a ton of
Chiefs fans there tonight
they're usually as I went to the
Chargers game in you know Carson the
first of the opening game Chiefs yeah
and it was basically a home game so the
poor Chargers they just gonna they play
an away game every game I know that's
the way it was in yesterday you know
there were a bunch of Broncos fans we're
celebrating there as well and maybe that
changes when they open up the new
stadium here in a couple of years but
that had to be for you to be at that
game week one with Patrick mahomes
coming out of the chute the way that he
did in that day and Tyreke he'll run it
all over the place that had to be
exhilarating but also a little bit of a
relief for you going into the season a
lot of people were wondering where we're
still wondering if mahomes was ready for
this primetime gig oh absolutely I mean
we had we had Alec Smith which oh I just
wish him the best you know we had Alex
Smith we had that quarterback and and
we'd have you know Travis Kelce we we'd
have talent every now and then great
talent but we never could have it all
together all at once that's what this
feels like it feels like oh my gosh
we've got a quarterback that can throw
it all the way down to the fastest
entire Hill you know you we've we've got
that guy that can take Andy Reid's
coaching and make it happen it's that
that I don't know what to call it it's
just that perfect place that you just
feel good about it you feel like to the
last second we have a chance it just
feels different yeah it does filled it
with with as you said you know Alex
Smith it just felt at times that there
was a struggle there was a on occasion
there would be some droughts and some
points challenged moments that would
also crop up at the most inopportune
moments and that might not be just on
him it might also have been the rest of
the roster it seems that these that the
roster is just with Sammy Watkins and
Travis Kelce now getting to be years
down the road and Kareem hunt with a
second year of going at it it just seems
it's all better and clicking right now
it just seems it's all better it they
that that there's not gonna be that
weird penalty that that we're not far
enough ahead to get over you know it
just seems like we're a four-quarter
team and so how far back does your
fandom go I know you just you hit that
in the television only segment but it's
not a larger audience on the radio born
and raised in Leavenworth Kansas
my father was big into the sports he was
a big sports guy right we started in the
in the 60s watching them you know in the
64 65 and when I was a baby I just I was
remembered so when I was about 9 or 10
we finally got in the Super Bowl and
when you win the Super Bowl and you're
that age and your whole family in a
neighborhood and city and the whole area
goes nuts you remember that and it makes
you a fan for life and I've been there
ever since and it's been a long time
since I felt this way yeah I know and
Len Dawson was the quarterback defense
was so gnarly was the last game of the
afl-nfl where they were two separate
things and so we beat the Minnesota
Vikings we they had they had not played
the AFL defense before and we just knew
we just beat the heck out of Davis
before Lamar Hunt came up with the term
of Super Bowl right he's the one who
came up with you know let's call this
AFL you got to come up with a new name
for this AFL versus NFL thing let's call
it Super Bowl the hunts are just beloved
in Kansas's right so woman's the last
time you were out in my city saying last
year I sang the anthem at the it was the
Chiefs Steelers game they had been
undefeated until that game right so I am
but everybody thinks it's that shirt you
wore it's the what you ate you know oh
my god they lost because I wore that
shirt so of course it was my fault I
sang the anthem soul-searching course I
did I actually this is funny I actually
was asked by the NFL because tonight
they're the Rams are are giving a lot of
tickets out to the the the first
responders the firemen and women that
helped us during this crisis that is
still ongoing in California with the
wildfires and they were and our home was
evacuated for five days with my family
our home is fine but they were looking
for you know people who had been
affected and the NFL actually asked me
to sing the anthem and then they said
well we'll run it by the Rams
but the Rams know what a Chiefs fan I am
blessed which makes it that actually
makes me feel good it's like we would
love to any other time but we know what
a Chiefs fans she is and that's a lot
I'm proud of that it's funny that I'll
tell the story on the air I you know
even though I don't know if I'm telling
the details out of school but Steve
bisciotti the owner of the Ravens ok
told me this story that Stacy Keibler
who was on Dancing with the Stars and
was a former Ravens cheerleader was
dating George Clooney at the time and
asked for tickets to come to the game in
Baltimore cuz Clooney's Bengals were
playing and he asked he said you know I
would normally have you in my suite I'll
put you somewhere else but this is my
team I cannot have a bangle fan even if
it is George Clooney in my suite but
don't you love the dedication that we
have football I I will play a show I
will have the whole audience in my in my
control in Oakland and all I have and
I'll walk out with my Kansas City Chiefs
ass drive a guitar strap okay and they
hate me
they just instant I'll be in Denver and
I'll just go to even I'll be in New
England in the Patriots and they're
cheering
the entire show they're coming to you
right you're paying money and so once
once you mention football though it's
over my wife's always like don't say
anything don't say anything I can't help
it so you can respect the fact that the
right users I love that oh I'd love the
I respect that they're like no I'll tell
you though I am you know I haven't
talked about it much on the show but
I'll do it with you right here Melissa
Etheridge here on the Rich Eisen show I
think that that might be the difference
in the game tonight is the emotion that
you're just saying that that I'm not not
singing the anthem so that again tonight
you know just last week and you can
attest to this to being a Los Angeles
resident yes then yet the way the Rams
were in the midst of the fires literally
figuratively the way that Andrew
Whitworth the left tackle donated his
check to the victims of the Thousand
Oaks shooting ok the way that the Rams
were living in that community and
supported the community and were part of
what was going on they became a Los
Angeles team for good you know but
obviously when you come into town it
takes some time to get into a Los
Angeles sports scene that they once were
part of but I think that's tonight as
good that might be the difference maker
in a way it will and and I'm here to say
that no matter what my Chiefs win
tonight you know they win in a way that
like even when we played the Patriots I
felt good after that loss it was like I
seen my team you know they played well
and and no matter what happens tonight I
think it's just going to be awesome
football just to be there and I know I
know and that you could save I guess the
moral victories are fine now to just
hope you don't they don't come in
January you know that's the idea that's
if you're a Chiefs man that's where
you're like Oh January I know but you're
right though to see mahomes take the
take the the first half lumps a couple
of interceptions you know the Belichick
style of confusing young kids for him to
take those lumps and then come back
in the fourth quarter that was really
something else so who's your favorite
chief I know I'm putting you on the spot
you are you know I got a there's so many
of them Travis Kelce probably he's he's
fire command can dance
the man has soul the man he he his
passion for it here's talent he's in
what he does for Kansas City is amazing
so I gotta say Travis Kelce he is he is
all that in the business yeah and a
biscuit his he he really I mean I just
love his as you said he's got a certain
way about him and the way that he has
potentially you feel that forgive me
there is a patriot fan over there in
Brockman he has this year of surpassed
Gronk
let me maybe not all time by the terms
of right now right here right now crock
hasn't played 2018 I know yeah but I
mean he is the best tight end in the
national football right now and fun to
watch athletic and you just never know
what he's gonna do yeah just don't throw
a flag to the flags around don't stop
breathe breathe move I'm always like
okay dude no it's all right right just
go back to the and in terms of tonight's
game I loved it I loved chopping it up
with you here with Melissa Etheridge
here on the Rich Eisen show is that I
think tonight Tyreke Hill going at
Marcus Peters former chief Oh I think
the Chiefs would really like to as
because of how much heat they did take
in the local area of sending Marcus
Peters packing yeah I think by the way
to say that ten times fast Marcus Peters
Becky I know it's that that I think that
that might be the way that the Chiefs
surpass all the obvious stuff that's
going on on the field as well as the
emotions of what's going on off of it
I'm so excited about the game like you
want it to start right now
yeah well I'm pretty much going back
home and get my kids and go to the game
well then you're going on the NFL
Network later on I got a text from
everybody there it's
I really have to say I love that the NFL
has embraced that I'm a huge fan it just
it tickles me it's really thrilling well
that's great
I love are you fantasy football as well
or no I have to have a life drooler and
I can't I can't when you find yourself
rooting against your team okay that's
weird
and your your so your holiday tour
starts just like right yeah starting
Friday hitting the road you're in
Beverly Massachusetts come on okay my
Chiefs okay let's walk through it here
you're not Alexander Virginia's that's
Redskins country so I'll give a little
love to Alex there you go he's such a
good guy I know he is really good people
I don't think there's a coach or
something if he doesn't come back you
know yeah I mean it is it's an awful
injury and obviously Theismann it's the
same thing that thighs me huh I know I'm
the same day but nobody was there
I know and now there's a photograph of
you right up there I know he came over
eyes he was walking down I said I said
Alex just melissa etheridge and that's
where I said he's the only man I'd write
a love song about and that's why I'm a
little torn now with the Patrick mahomes
thing I feel but I have a lot of exes
thing you know and I can that's okay
write songs about him okay and then
you're gonna wind up in the Michigan see
I have you ever played the Michigan
theatre before and I think I have a
fridge calm for tickets and then the
Melissa Etheridge cruise come on March
31st to April 7th everyone everyone
every type of music lover I've got great
artists Paula Cole Shawn Colvin Joan
Osborne we're sailin it's good music
good run come on the Melissa Etheridge
cruise comm for tickets and more
information thanks for coming on here my
pleasure I hope to see you again soon
where we talk about playoffs or
something yes well I mean you know I'm
very excited for it by the way do you
know tonight is I think the last time
Andy Reid was at the LA Coliseum at the
punt pass kick did you have you ever
seen the video of
the punt pass and kick is a
thirteen-year-old kid yes he's so
massive these little kids in him nobody
knew at the time it was like a wireless
phone yeah reception bar is what it
looked like but he was a 13 year old kid
in the LA Coliseum of the halftime of
Redskins Rams of Monday Night Football
December 13th 1971 I looked it up for
yesterday's show and we think that's the
last time he was at the LA Coliseum why
I told tonight that's exciting I love me
some Andy Reid I just love what he's
done to the Chiefs love it okay as much
as you love ketchup okay no or are you a
vegan like a straight-up Vee no no I'm a
pescetarian
a pescetarian yeah do you think Andy's
you know talk to you about it yeah I
think you'd really love that I love it
on Twitter again Melissa Etheridge comm
for tickets and information on the
annual holiday tour that starting up
this Friday Wow and then the Melissa
Etheridge cruise D Melissa Etheridge
cruise comm the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience